Okay, so we divided up the brain one way.
Now we’re going to divide it up another
way, so this is the brain from the top down.
You know you have two hemispheres and you
might think, “well why do you need two hemispheres?”
Do know that Gazzaniga, who’s a relatively
famous neuropsychologist, studied split-brain
patients.
You know that your cortical hemispheres – your
brain is united down in the sub-cortical areas.
It’s sort of stuck together, although you
have twins of many of the sub-cortical structures.
You have two hippoc8ampi and two amygdala
for example – one on each side.
At the top, the hemispheres are quite separate,
but they’re connected by the corpus callosum,
which makes them communicate.
It’s kind of interesting because you wonder
why they aren’t all glued together.
What it seems to indicate is that there’s
some utility of functional independence, combined
with some utility of communication.
So it might be like, “do you really want
to be networked at the same time to everyone
in the world?”
No you don’t, you want some narrow pathway
so that only the important information comes
through.
So it’s sort of like, maybe the right hemisphere’s
the one kind of computational device, and
the left hemisphere is another kind of computational
device – of course they’re not computational
devices, but you get the point.
Only the important information – the processed
information from the right hemisphere goes
across.
And only the processed information from the
left hemisphere goes across.
Something like that, whatever.
If you have someone who’s epileptic or that
has a brain illness of some sort, it’s usually
epilepsy but not always, and you do surgery
on them and cut the corpus callosum; what
you find, weirdly enough, is that each hemisphere
develops its own personality.
This is other evidence, I would say, for the
idea that what the brain does is produce personalities.
You can keep paring the brain down, and what
it’s going to do is produce lower and lower
resolution personalities all the way down
to the bottom – they’re just not as detailed.
If you lost, say eighty percent of your cortex
randomly, you’d sort of being like a thumbnail
of yourself.
So, you’d still be you, just not at the
same detail.
Here’s an interesting idea from the Catholics,
it kind of goes along with the avatar idea.
So the Catholics had been wrestling for a
long time with the question of how God could
have fit himself in a human body– because
you could imagine that could obsess Christians
– this great, big God in an itty-bitty body,
but God in there just bursts the boundaries.
They have this idea called Kenosis, which
means emptying.
The idea is that God had to empty himself
out before he could inhabit a human body,
and it’s very much like a thumbnail idea.
Jung would have of course thought exactly,
that the self was a thumbnail of God.
He wouldn’t put it that way, but definitely
that’s where his thinking was leading.
So that’s a pretty damn cool idea.
Anyways, so I developed this before I read
what I’m going to tell you, but it doesn’t
matter.
I’m going to talk about it from another
theorist’s point of view.
The guy I’m going to tell you about, his
name is Elkhonon Goldberg.
He’s a neuropsychologist, and he was one
of Luria’s students who ended up in New
York.
Goldberg was obviously influenced by Luria
and all the unknown, Grey, and all those people
that I’ve already talked to you about.
He was interested in why you have two hemispheres.
Well, there’s a bunch of things you can
say, broadly speaking about the hemispheres,
and I’ve written some of them down there.
The right hemisphere – this is an idealized
representation of a relatively highly lateralized
right-handed male.
The reason I’m saying that is men seem to
be more lateralized than women, and the right-handed
lateralization is the standard kind.
The brain can be lateralized all sorts of
ways.
What you might say is that – there’s a
bunch of ways of looking at it.
One way you can look at it is that your cortex
gets colonized by underlying structures.
Each underlying structure is likely to colonize
a particular area.
For example, when you are born and you wake
up and you see, your eyes are going to colonize
your visual cortex most likely.
It’s sort of adapted for that.
If you don’t have a visual cortex then your
eyes will colonize something else.
So the brain has proclivities towards a certain
kind of structure, especially early in development,
it’s unbelievably plastic, and so brains
can be organized and lateralized in a bunch
of different ways.
To simplify it, what you do is you kind of
take, well let’s take the most straight-forward
and typical brain and talk about it as if
it’s the canonical brain.
I think what you can say is, regardless of
where these systems are localized, they exist.
So it’s an oversimplification – whatever,
doesn’t matter.
What you’ve got with regards to your cortices
is a quick and dirty cortex, that’s the
right hemisphere, and then you’ve got a
long-term detailed cortex and that’s the
left hemisphere.
The left hemisphere is specialized for language.
Language cuts things up into little, tiny,
bitty pieces.
That’s really useful if you’re doing little,
tiny, bitty things.
You should be – precision, right?
Pinpoint accuracy; but that takes a lot of
time and a lot of computation.
Whereas the right hemisphere says, “yeah,
yeah, let’s get to the bloody point.”
So it captures the thing in an image.
So like the monster I showed you from the
hippie cartoon, that’s a right hemisphere
thing.
It’s an image that represents a class of
entities; which, of course, images do.
There’s this woman named - can’t remember
- autistic woman.
She’s developed paddle-handling facilities
all across –
“what’s her name?”
Student “Temple Grandin.”
Temple Grandin, yes a very cool person.
Yes I saw Temple Grandin speak at the University
of Arizona at the Consciousness Conference,
and it was the funniest speech I’ve ever
seen in my life.
Not because it wasn’t perfect – it was
bloody perfect.
She’s a tough woman – she looks a like
a cowboy, and she spent a lot of time with
animals.
She comes out on the stage in her cowboy outfit
and she’s unbelievably straightforward and
without nuance – she’s autistic, she’s
severely autistic.
You know, her mother helped her a lot, she
developed this thing that she would go inside
to compress her and hold her – like a little
machine and that would comfort her.
Anyways, she turned herself into quite the
person and she thinks, she thinks like an
animal.
This is why she can design cattle handling
facilities, which are often slaughter houses,
so that the cattle don’t get all freaked
out as they’re on their way to their eventual
demise.
So one of the things she does, is she walks
through where the cattle are going, and anything
that bothers her, she assumes will bother
a cow.
So for example, if the cows are walking through
this spiral as they’re on their way to the
slaughter-house and there’s a coke can lying
on the ground, all the cows will stop and
look at the coke can – it’s anomalous.
Now, she talked a lot about how she thought
and what she said was that she could not devise
abstract representations.
So she said, okay, imagine how a child draws
a house.
What is in that child’s house?
There’s a triangle and a square on the left,
and then there’s another rectangle, and
another parallelogram, and there’s a door
and two windows, right?
Then there’s a chimney with smoke coming
out – which is quite cool, it’s like why
is that?
Where’s the smoke?
You don’t see that in modern houses, but
kids still do that.
And then there’s a tree, and usually there’s
a sun, and then - house.
You think, oh, isn’t that cute, a simple
drawing.
That drawing is not simple.
You’ve never seen a house that looks like
that in your life.
It looks nothing like a house.
It’s not a house, it’s not a picture,
it’s a hieroglyph.
It’s a pre-linguistic representation.
It’s like the essential elements of “house.”
So you might say what the child has done is
extracted out all those things that are common
across all houses, and then represented that.
It’s not a drawing.
Now if you take autistic people, sometimes,
and you get them to draw, they’ll start
in one corner of the house, and what they’ll
draw is that house – with every damn brick
in place.
So there are autistic people, for example,
who – they can look at a building and they
can count every single window at one glance.
Then, there’s another guy in England who’s
really famous, and this guy is unbelievable.
You take him up in a helicopter and show him
a city that he’s never seen, then he goes
home and has a piece of paper, like as big
as a wall, and he starts in one corner and
he draws the entire city.
He doesn’t sketch it out – it’s from
the bottom up.
That’s autistic savant drawing.
Often what happens is, it’s very realistic
looking.
What happens if the autistic drawings of blank
language is they stop being able to draw.
That’s because the abstraction interferes
with the realism.
It’s really hard to draw a hand.
The reason for that is if you draw a hand,
you draw a hieroglyph of hand.
This is what a hand looks like.
You try to draw your hand and it’s really
strange.
One of the really strange things about trying
to draw your hand is that in order to draw
it, you have to stop seeing it as if it’s
a hand.
Then it pops out and you think, my God, that’s
the weirdest looking thing.
It’s like a tree root, you know, it’s
like a claw.
You know if you look at your hand like that,
it looks nothing like a hand.
That’s how a hand looks.
What the hell’s that?
It’s like some sort of spider, but you have
to see it that way before you can draw it.
So partly what happens is, is that your capacity
for abstraction interferes with your ability
to see detail, that’s probably good – it’s
one of the ways that you simplify the world.
Anyways, the right hemisphere looks like it’s
specialized for anomaly.
The way I look at it is this: Okay, so you’ve
got your hippocampus down there, and it’s
keeping track of the comparison between what
you want and what you think is happening.
“Bang!”
Something emerges, and it’s anomalous.
You don’t know what the hell’s going on.
So you freeze, that’s the notoric representation.
Then you start to feel anxious.
Then the right hemisphere comes up with some
pictures – what might this be?
You can experience this at home, for your
own enjoyment.
Let’s say you’re home at two in the morning,
it’s dark and you’re alone.
Maybe you’ve watched a horror movie, so
you’re all nicely blank.
You know and then you hear a noise in another
room and that noise shouldn’t be there.
So you’re going to go investigate, right?
So let’s say the door’s just a little
bit open, and it’s dark in the room, and
you have to put your hand in to turn on the
light.
You just watch what your imagination populates
that room with when you do that.
You know, it’s like – guy with axe, snake,
alligator, like whatever!
You’re right hemisphere is going: there
may be one of this class of dangerous thing
in there.
What it’s doing is it’s basically coming
up with a hypothesis: what sort of monster
might be in there.
You’re all freaked out about that, even
though you know – who knows what happened;
nothing but something creaked, but you’re
all on edge because your brain doesn’t work
at night like it does during the day.
Everyone knows that – wake up in the middle
of the night, a manner of horrors go through
your imagination, and that usually happens
when you’re asleep.
You’re asleep for that most of the time,
but sometimes you wake up and you worry about
everything.
Anyways, so that’s the right hemisphere
– it’s coming up with pictures of what
might be there.
They’re generally monstrous pictures and
the reason for that is, well it’s obvious,
what the reason for that is.
You’ll probably turn the light on and look
anyways, even though you might sort of peer
around the corner, and then when there’s
nothing you’ll be embarrassed about how
foolish you are.
But you can see the instinctual behavior right
there, and it’s wise.
You know, there’s a low probability that
something terrible is there.
Low probability times infinitely equals large
danger.
So if there’s a two percent chance that
there’s a killer in there, it pays to be
a little on the tense side, because being
killed really sucks.
So you’re primed to feel negative emotion
more intensely, because you’re so vulnerable.
Anyways, that’s kind of what the right hemisphere
is up to – it does quick and dirty representations.
It also does categorization, so it’s not
– it doesn’t give you exactly realistic
representations of what’s there.
What it does instead, is it gives you categorical
representations.
So you might say, “how should you represent
an unknown danger?”
You should use an amalgam of all known dangers
to represent it.
That is what it is in a sense, you know?
That’s why I talked to you about the category
of “all dangerous things.”
So the Aboriginals in Australia have this
category which is, “women, fire, and dangerous
things.”
Well you think, well why are all of those
things in that category?
It’s not that hard to figure out if you
think about it, but it’s also a category
that you very frequently see, say in Disney
cartoons.
So the Wicked Queen, for example, in Sleeping
Beauty – she’s constantly bursting into
flames and turning into a dragon and no one
seems to object to that – it makes perfect
sense that the Wicked Queen would turn into
a fire-breathing dragon.
It doesn’t make any sense at all, although
it does, but it’s not a rational transformation.
But because it’s in keeping with an archetypal
structure, everybody goes, “yeah, of course
that’s what she’s going to do.”
It happens all of the time in Disney movies
– like Ursula, remember her from the Little
Mermaid?
She’s trying to keep her daughter from becoming
conscious.
Yeah, nice Mother doing that.
She traps old Zeus – she squeezes his soul
to death and traps him in the underworld.
He’s also – well, we won’t get into
that.
Anyways, what happens to Ursula is when you
finally get her irritated enough she grows
into this huge, ship-destroying, storm monster
that’s part octopus – a giant octopus.
You think, “well, that makes sense.”
Okay, it doesn’t make a lot of sense, but
it’s a kind of hypothesis.
Now that’s a representation of Mother Nature
– red and tooth and claw, and there’s
also a reason that’s female – it’s not
female, it’s feminine – it’s actually
a different thing.
We’ll get to that.
So the right hemisphere, well it’s specialized
for anomaly – it does quick and dirt analysis
under the influence of the limbic system.
It’s not linguistic, so I would say that
it’s still dominated by the sub-cortical
systems.
My suspicion is that animals are still dominated
by the sub-cortical systems.
Their brains work from the bottom up.
We have a top down module.
That’s at least in part of the left hemisphere
linguistic system.
It’s a new thing that people have, and it’s
based on our capacity to abstract, so that
would partly be visual, like hieroglyphic,
and then also to transform things into linguistic
form.
It seems to me that that’s the part that
we really identify as ourselves, right?
It’s weird – let’s say you’re home
alone, and you get freaked out and all these
images come to mind; do you think of those
images as part of you?
You think of them more as these things that
appeared to you.
That’s what you think about your dreams.
They’re things that appeared to you - they’re
not you.
Why would you think that?
I mean, they’re in your experiential space,
so why is there that separation between you
and your dream?
“I had a dream.”
Not, “I thought up a dream.”
Or, “look what I created,” it’s like
there you are, the observer, and up comes
a dream.
It’s very, very weird.
It shows you that there are forces operating
in your psyche that are impersonal, genuinely
impersonal.
That’s part of what you call the collective
unconscious.
It’s the thing that generates these weird
images and protects you.
It’s nature, that’s for sure.
It can be absolutely terrifying.
People can have dreams that are so terrible
– well like the one my little nephew had,
that’s pretty damn nasty; little greasy
dwarf things with big beaks, that’s a very
ugly representation, and if that wasn’t
bad enough there had to be a fire-breathing
dragon behind them, creating them endlessly.
There’s no bloody-wonder he was waking up
screaming.
It’s like, “Oh no, I figured out what
life is like.”
At four, that’s pretty traumatic.
So, okay, now the left hemisphere.
This is Elkonon Goldberg’s hypothesis.
You get one hemisphere or system that operates
when you know what you’re doing and when
what you want is happening.
That’s the happy-talky part that thinks
it knows what-the-hell is going on.
Then you have another part that only turns
on when you don’t know what’s going on.
It’s full of anxiety and negative emotion.
The right hemisphere, by the way, is specialized
for negative emotion.
If you sustain right, pre-frontal damage,
you become inappropriately happy.
You’re full of positive illusions.
You think, “well, that’s an excellent
thing.”
It’s not – you make really impulsive risky
decisions and your life goes directly to hell.
You need the negative emotion, obviously.
The reason you suffer with negative emotion
is because if you didn’t suffer with negative
emotion, you’d suffer from being destroyed.
Those are your options.
There are people, by the way, who are born
without pain.
You think, “hey, that’s a good deal.”
They never last past twenty, and part of the
reason for that is – you don’t notice
this – but while you’re sitting there,
you’re going like this all the time.
The reason for that is that if you sit for
any length of time on one part of your body,
then it doesn’t get much blood and it doesn’t
get oxygenated.
You do that, it bitches a little bit, a little
pain, so you shift.
You shift and you shift, so you’re just
doing this all of the time.
Otherwise you wear out your damn body and
you get bed sores, or that sort of thing.
These people that don’t have any pain, they
just wear themselves out.
So you need the negative emotion, it keeps
you going.
It can get out of hand and have its own pathologies,
but it’s definitely necessary.
So the right hemisphere does negative emotion.
Inhibition of behavior – that’s the freezing
that’s attended on anxiety.
It does image processing, holistic thinking
– so it’s the quick and dirty hemisphere
- pattern recognition, pattern generation
and gross motor action.
That’s interesting too, because the gross
motor action is, again, the quick and dirty
stuff.
If you need to slap something away, it doesn’t
really matter that it’s a gross-motor gesture.
You don’t have to go like this, and be precise;
it can just be fast and sloppy, and it will
still work.
Now the left hemisphere is specialized for
when you know what-the-hell’s going on and
you can concentrate on the details.
So then you can think about it in terms of
the hierarchy that we discussed, right?
So what it implies is that at the level of
specific, fine, detailed motor output, the
left hemisphere is operating.
That’s kind of associated with positive
affect – I know exactly what I’m doing
and I’m making minor adjustments and everything’s
going well.
If you go up the hierarchy towards more and
more abstracted representations then increasingly,
that’s moving over to right hemisphere space.
So that’s also partly why, when you disrupt
those higher-order structures, literally all
hell breaks loose.
So, left hemispheres.
Operation in explored territory – positive
emotion, activation of behavior, so that’s
also exploration.
Word processing, linear thinking, detail recognition,
detail generation, and fine motor action.
So you need one system that works when you
don’t know what’s going on and you need
another system that works when you do.
Sometimes you’re where you don’t know
what you’re doing and sometimes you’re
where do know what you’re doing.
Now Ramachandran, who’s a fairly famous
neurologist, who operates out of LA, he associated
the totalitarian ego with hyper domination
of the left hemisphere.
The reason he did that is very cool.
So he’s got these patients that have – what’s
it called, is it agnosia?
It isn’t, we’ll call it neglect.
Okay so this is what happens.
You have a stroke and the stroke affects the
back part of the right hemisphere, alright?
So what happens?
Your left side is paralyzed; you can’t do
anything with it.
Okay, so, however you also don’t notice
that it’s not working, so one of the things
you might do if you do become aware – you’re
laying in bed, you’ve had a stroke and for
some reason you notice that there’s an arm
lying in there with you.
Then what you do is you try to pick it up
with your other hand and you try to throw
it out of the bed.
When you find out that it’s attached to
you, because it’s not your arm, you’re
not very happy – or maybe you throw yourself
right out of bed.
Then if someone gets you to draw a clock you
draw half a clock and if you eat a plateful
of food you eat half the plate, unless someone
turns it – and then you eat half of that.
So half the world is gone – it’s hard
to imagine what that would be like.
I think what it’s sort of like is – you
know how there’s a whole world behind you?
You don’t detect it as not there – it’s
not black or anything, like when your eyes
are closed – it’s just not there.
I think what happens with people with neglect
is that the “not there” becomes three
quarters instead of just half.
It’s something like that anyways.
You don’t know what’s going on and there
you are like this and someone says to you,
“I notice that you can’t move your left
arm today.”
What do you say?
You say, “that’s because I’m tired.”
Or, “I don’t feel like moving it.”
And so forth, so you have this reason that
you’re not going to move it.
You might say the same thing about the left
foot, “yeah well I don’t feel like moving
it.
“ You’ll have some story about why you’re
not going to move it.
Okay so that’s fine.
Freudian’s thought about that is traumatic
denial.
It was so overwhelming to you that you lost
the left part of your body.
You couldn’t face it and you just denied
it happened.
It’s not a bad theory, it’s not quite
right, but it’s not a bad theory.
I’ll tell you a couple of related stories.
Let’s say you’re on dialysis.
That sucks.
You have to have this big thing in your arm,
it’s like a shunt, and you have to go get
hooked up to a dialysis machine like all the
time.
Your kidneys are failing and who wants that?
Nobody, so everybody thinks: time for a kidney
transplant, and then they’re on a long waiting
list and they get one kidney.
That’s not very many kidneys.
Then they say, “okay, you got your kidney
and everyone’s thrilled about that, here’s
your anti-rejection medication, make sure
you take it.
Then a year later you lose your kidney, why?
You don’t take your damn anti-rejection
medication, that’s the most common reason.
You might think, well why in the world would
you not take your anti-rejection medication?
The Freudians would say denial.
Here’s a different hypothesis: Your whole
map of you is person with kidney.
Then you lose your kidneys and it’s like
you’re a whole, weird thing that you have
no idea about.
It’s virtually impossible for you to update
your model.
You think, does that make any sense?
Have you ever lost a tooth?
Right.
What does your tongue do for six months?
You’re sitting there and your tongue is
fiddling away there like a mad dog investigating
every teensy nook and cranny like it’s an
obsessive exploratory device.
It does it even when you don’t want it to.
Then six months later you get your mouth remapped.
That’s just a tooth, man; lose a kidney
and see what happens.
Or lose the whole left side of you body, it’s
like, what are you going to do about that?
Well, okay, then Ramachandran, he’s testing
these people for balance.
What he does is he checks out this phenomena
called nystagmus, and so if you pour cold
water in someone’s ear their eyes will move
back and forth because it screws up the – you
know you have a balance system in you, in
ear your ear – and if you pour cold water
in there it screws it up and then your eyes
move back and forth.
You know, it’s not very pleasant.
What he found was that if he poured cold water
in the left ear, then all of a sudden the
people would wake up and go, “Oh my God,
I don’t have the left side of my body,”
and then they’d have a catastrophic emotional
experience and they’d be all upset about
it crying away; which is of course what they
should do.
Twenty minutes later it would wear off and
you’d say is there anything wrong with your
left side and they’d say well yeah, I just
don’t feel like moving it.
So what seems to have happened is something
– so there’s a body representation center
in the back of the right hemisphere.
You blow that sucker out with a stroke, and
that means that you can’t represent that
part of your body anymore.
Maybe there are tatters of it left; it’s
like a network that’s damaged and under
some conditions you can more or less get it
to operate so you pour some cold water in
the ear and you shock the whole system.
Then there’s enough neurological activity
so the network kicks in, even though it’s
damaged for ten minutes, and then you get
this tremendous burst of negative emotion
- which is what the right hemisphere should
be doing when you lose half of your body.
You experience that when your left hemisphere
is flapping away trying to account for this
– which it can’t, because it’s such
a massive, utter catastrophe.
Then you know, the shock wears off and “bang!”
the system shuts back down, and “poof!”
you’re back in denial.
That’s a good example of the relationship
between the left hemisphere and the right
hemisphere.
The left hemisphere has a fixed idea about
the world.
So in some sense you might think about it
as the instantiation of your latest avatar;
you can certainly see that with people who
are ideologically possessed.
They’ve got this verbal system that accounts
for the whole world and there’s just no
damn way that thing’s going anywhere.
It’s got this totalitarian aspect because
it wants to explain every last thing; it doesn’t
like anomaly at all.
It hasn’t come to terms with anomaly at
all.
There’s no sense of transformation within
the system, which is partly why totalitarian
systems die.
The Red Queen said to Alice in Wonderland
when she was in the underworld, “in my kingdom
you have to run as fast as you can just to
stay in the same place.”
That’s why totalitarian systems don’t
work.
The damn environment keeps shifting around
on them.
If they’re fixed in place, the gap between
their theory and reality gets larger and larger
and larger and larger until finally they fall
into a pit; and that’s the end of it.
That’s what happens to people too, if they
don’t stay updated.
They let things get away on them; eventually
the ignored reality comes flooding back, and
we’ll see that represented in mythology
because it’s represented very nicely in
mythology.
It’s why often dragons in fairytales, for
example, in the Saint George story, and in
the Hobbit for that matter – the dragon
is an eternal thing: it lives underneath the
earth and most of the time it leaves you the
hell alone.
Now and then it comes back and it tries to
destroy the city, and then you have to zip
out there and fight the thing so you can get
it to go back in its hole.
Maybe you get the treasure that it’s carrying,
and then it’s back in the hole for while;
but that thing’s coming back.
It’s always coming back, and so you build
the walls and all that, that’s fine.
A dragon can destroy any walls.
Walls aren’t enough – you have to be prepared
to go out there and fight the damn thing,
and that’s how you keep it at bay.
That basically means you have to maintain
everything that you build, it’s something
like that, right?
Otherwise it falls apart with increasing entropy.
Alright, so
Goldberg thought about this as an anomaly
system, a novelty system and a routinization
system.
I intended to think about it from more of
an Anthropological or an Ethological perspective;
thinking about an animal (us) in our natural
environment.
It’s not so much novelty versus routinization,
as it’s explored versus unexplored territory.
That’s what the world’s made out of – it’s
made out of explored versus unexplored territory.
So there’s a domain that you inhabit, which
is the center of the universe, from a mythological
perspective, with you right in the middle
of it.
Around you is this circle, which is your place,
which you move around with you, and in that
circle you know what-the-hell’s going on.
That’s partly because you’ve mapped it,
but it’s also partly because you don’t
go outside of it.
You have your friends and you have your routine
and that’s nested inside your culture, and
you try and keep that thing from flipping
upside down.
You do that all sorts of way: partly by doing
the same thing all the time, but also partly
by refusing to go anywhere that might seriously
challenge your beliefs.
Fair enough, you can understand that, although
it makes you weak to do that, because you’re
not as prepared as you might be.
So you could say human beings are tribal,
social animals that have a territory.
Then you think, “well what’s the territory?”
Well let’s say tree-dwelling chimp ancestors;
the territory’s the jungle.
No, it’s not.
That’s not the territory.
The territory is a little bit of the jungle,
plus the things that come in from the outside,
plus the primate dominance hierarchy that
exists in that area.
So that’s the territory, that’s the environment.
For mythological reasons we tend to make a
separation between the environment and culture.
Yes, it makes sense at one level of analysis,
but at another level of analysis all it does
is screw you up.
You’re territory, fundamentally, isn’t
the world; not the natural, objective world.
You want to stay as far away from that thing
as you possibly can.
Your territory is that circle of people with
whom you spend ninety percent of your time.
If you’re a chimp, for example, or some
other kind of monkey, highly social, what
do you do all day?
You sleep, you eat, you chew leaves if you’re
a chimp, and you groom other chimps.
It’s constant social interaction, and you’re
jockeying for a position in the dominance
hierarchy like mean girls in that movie, you
know.
You’re mapping out the social territory
knowing who’s who, and what’s what, and
then trying to get up somewhere near the top.
That’s your environment, that’s your environment,
and so your world is that social, natural
circle, which is a four-dimensional territory,
because its got length, width and height – plus
it stretches across time.
So it’s this transforming natural entity.
Inside that there’s a pyramid.
The pyramid is made out of all the primates
that you interact with.
That’s the world; circle with a pyramid
on it.
Now I’ll give you a vision, this is a vision
I had once when I was trying to figure this
stuff out.
Now what is the world?
So imagine that there’s a field in front
of you that stretches as far as you can see.
You’re flying above it.
What you see everywhere are these pyramids.
Let’s say for the sake of argument, that
they’re skyscrapers made out of glass.
There are tears in them.
You fly down and one’s here and one’s
here, and some of them are really big and
some of them are really small.
They’re just everywhere.
You’re flying around above them, and you
fly close enough to look inside and what you
see inside them are people all packed together,
trying to scramble up to the top.
That’s the world, that’s reality.
The funny thing is, is that you can be in
one of those pyramids clambering away to the
top, or you can be flying above it – those
are your options.
If you have to choose, you should be flying
above it.
So the relationship between the self and the
ego avatar is the same as the relationship
between the thing that’s flying above, and
the thing that’s within one of those pyramids
trying to scramble to the top.
You know, well you say well I’m going to
get to the top.
“Top of what?”
There’s a hundred tops, there’s two hundred
tops.
Then you might say, “well is there anything
above the top?”
There is, there’s the part of you that isn’t
entrapped within that particular system and
that can move from place to place.
If you look at Egyptian mythology: so you
know you’ll see if you look at the back
of the American dollar bill, that’s a symbol
of value, right?
Okay, so what’s the pyramid?
There’s a pyramid on it, right?
What’s the top of a pyramid?
It’s a triangle, it’s separate from the
pyramid.
There’s an eye inside of it.
That’s because the top of the pyramid is
an eye, and it’s separate from the pyramid.
What that means, fundamentally, is that the
thing that transcends the structure is attention,
voluntary attention.
Now the Egyptians worshiped voluntary attention
in the form of Horus, because he was a God.
I’ll tell you about Horus in detail.
One of Horus’ avatars was the falcon.
The reason for that is falcons can really,
really, really see.
They fly around, and so they’re like the
king’s eyes.
Like the little bird Zazu in the Lion King.
He was the king’s eyes, the thing that flies
around above.
He was a particular enemy of Scar, remember
Scar eats him at the beginning and then spits
him out.
The reason that the King’s eyes is an enemy
of scar is because the King’s eyes can see
what he is, right?
He’s the eternal force that works to disrupt
the kingdom and bring everything into ruins.
Classic myth, classic myth, partly accounting
for why it was the largest selling, highest
grossing cartoon in Disney history.
They got the mythology pretty right.
So you might say, “what’s a human being
like?”
Remember I told you that when Penfield was
mapping the brain he was poking people.
You can either poke them along the sensory
strip, which is – if the motor strip is
here, the sensory strip is just behind it.
The motor strip is where the motor systems
of your body are represented in so far as
you can control them.
The sensory strip is where the sensory systems
are represented in so far as you can feel
them.
So what this is, is a – the body is laid
out weirdly on the motor cortex.
One of the things that’s pretty funny is
that the genitalia area in the sensory cortex
is right beside the feet.
So I think that’s why people have foot fetishes
and love foot massages, is because they’re
spreading activation from the foot area to
the genital area, and God only knows why that
is.
Maybe because you had to have had really sensitive
feet to stomp around without stepping on really
horrible things.
So you can put this weird, stretched-out,
body representation together in a representational
form like this, they call that the homunculus,
which is like a little-man that exists inside
your brain.
So what you see, that’s the motor-homunculus,
not the sensory-homunculus.
So what do you see?
Well what is a person as far as its brain
is concerned?
Well, hand – that’s for sure.
Thumb, that’s for sure – your thumb is
as representative of your whole body.
It’s because your torso is hardly represented
at all.
Why is that?
How many things do you manipulate with your
chest?
None.
You don’t have motor control over it, so
it’s not represented.
So, the hands man, those things, they’re
represented like mad.
So are the face, and the lips and the tongue.
There’s a bunch of reasons for that: One
is when you’re an infant, you explore like
mad with your mouth – but you do that your
whole life because when you eat- you know
what it’s like.
If you’re eating something and there’s
a bit of sand in it, you find it and you take
it out.
You can detect this teeny, little thing that’s
not supposed to be in your mouth.
Well that’s a good thing because lots of
things aren’t supposed to be in your mouth.
That’s part of the reason.
The other part of the reason is, well think
about what you do with your tongue?
There are a lot of things you do with your
tongue: Some of them are eating, some of them
are talking.
Some of them are all sorts of intimate behaviors,
that thing is wired up; and it’s wired up
right at birth.
Then it’s the same with your lips and the
rest of your mouth, you use that to communicate.
Your hands wander around, taking the world
apart, and putting it back together, which
is exactly what your brain does, and then
you blab about what you’re doing to everyone.
That’s basically a human being.
I like to think of this thing as it’s a
comical representation of the hero that goes
out to confront the world, right?
The hero has two elements.
One is explore, and that’s where the west
is powerful.
We have a really well developed mythology
of the exploratory hero.
Where we’re not so well developed is the
second part.
In the second part of the classic hero story,
you’re supposed to come back and communicate
about what you’ve found.
So if there’s an individual exploration
element, and then there’s a communicate
and update the culture element.
Both of those are equally important an it’s
something we don’t do well, we don’t have
much respect for tradition in the west, and
it’s a really, really big problem.
The ethical responsibility of a human being
is to take the dead culture, so that’s the
dead father, or the dead God, and to revivify
it with attention and communication.
If you fail to do that then everything disappears.
We’re failing to do that – we’re leaving
it all behind instead.
It’s not a good idea.
You know if the old Gods die as Nietzsche
said they had, new Gods swoop in very rapidly
and if you thought the old God was bad, you
wait until the new God gets a hold of you.
So, well we saw what happened in the twentieth
century, with all of the ideologies that sprang
up in the absence of classical religious belief.
Okay, you’re not so thrilled with Catholicism,
if you think about that as the fundamental
tradition of the West.
You know, with the witch burnings and the
inquisition and all that.
It’s like yeah, yeah, get a load of the
Nazis and then see what you think; or the
Communists for that matter - from bad to worse
in an unimaginable way.
You know, and it’s partly because those
archaic systems, those archaic, religious
systems, they weren’t ideologies, they were
a whole different class of thing.
We don’t understand them very well, and
it’s not good because you cannot live without
understanding them.
You don’t know who you are.
Then you fall prey to weird mental diseases,
like Nihilism, that’s one.
The other one is ideological possession – so
you become a Totalitarian or a Nihilist.
That’s a bad outcome.
You might think, “well, what’s the alternative?”
Well, you know what happens in Pinocchio,
right?
You’ve watched Pinocchio?
Okay, I often show Pinocchio to this class,
but I don’t know if I’m going to do that
this year.
Anyways, Pinocchio, he’s a puppet, a marionette.
Someone else is pulling his strings.
He has a wooden head.
He’s not very bright.
He hasn’t banged the world at all.
He’s got a good father, the old Geppetto,
who would really rather that he was a real
boy, a real person.
So he’s the kind of father that wants to
produce an individual, not a slave.
That’s why in his workshop it’s all friendly
and there’s a nice fire, and he’s making
toys and there’s lots of music, it’s like
“Go Geppetto!” he’s a good guy.
He makes this little puppet and he sends him
out in the world.
He says, “go be a real boy.”
Well, Pinocchio runs into a whole class of
different obstacles; one is evil, that’s
the Coachman, and the Italian stereotype guy
who makes him a dancing puppet celebrity.
I think that’s pretty funny, that’s really
prescient.
You might think well what’s the goal of
your typical bone-headed, mid-adolescent in
North America – unearned celebrity.
Well that’s exactly what Pinocchio goes
for first.
That doesn’t work out so well because he
ends up a slave and then the next thing that
happens is he capitalizes on the fact that
he’s vulnerable, and pretends he’s sick
and goes off for a vacation, under the direction
of the Coachman (who’s basically Satan in
disguise).
Then he goes out to treasure island and meets
all of the delinquents who are just like Nazis,
and turns out in fact the whole ploy is to
enslave everyone, to deprive them of their
voice – that’s the donkey’s breying
– and to make them into slaves.
Pretty damn horrifying and that movie came
out around the time that the Nazis were really
grasping power in central Europe.
They got it exactly right.
Here’s what’s really going on behind the
scenes.
Then what happens is Pinocchio turns halfway
into a braying donkey.
He’s gone off the path and in order to get
back on it he tries to go home.
It’s too late, he can’t go home, because
he’s not a kid anymore.
He goes home and Dad isn’t there, surprise,
surprise.
Once you grow up and you go home, Dad isn’t
there – it’s just another human being.
So then what happens is he has to go into
the ocean.
Well that’s particularly weird, right?
There he is, half donkey, he’s a puppet,
the dove comes down and drops him a message
from God.
It’s like the Holy Spirit descending, except
it’s from the blue fairy, weirdly enough.
The message says you have to go to the deepest
part of the ocean and rescue your father.
Yeah that is what you have to do if you don’t
want to be a bloody, puppet donkey.
You have to go down into the depths and find
your dead Father and you have to revivify
him.
That’s what happens.
So Pinocchio goes way down there into the
deepest depths and finds Monstro, who’s
a monster so terrible that the fish swim away
at the sound of his voice.
Just like, “he who shall not be named – Voldemort.”
You can’t even say his damn name.
Same with Monstro.
Pinocchio goes down there, he goes into the
whale, what happens?
Geppetto says there’s no getting out of
this, there’s no getting out of this.
We just have to sit here and cook fish and
Pinocchio thinks, “cook!”
He starts breaking up all the chairs and everything
and his Father is freaking out, “what are
you doing breaking all of these chairs?
What are we going to sit out?”
Pinocchio lights them on fire.
He’s a master of fire.
It’s a Shemanic ritual.
He is a master of fire and that’s what human
being is.
He gets everything burning, of course Geppetto’s
all freaked out about that because what are
the going to sit on, and Pinocchio thinks,
“who cares about sitting?
We’re going to solve the problem once and
for all.”
Then the whale turns into a fire-breathing
dragon, which is pretty damn weird thing for
a whale to do.
He half-kills Pinocchio, he washes up on shore
dead, but he saves his father.
Then at the very end of the movie he’s lying
on his bed, all drowned.
So he’s a dead puppet now.
Do you want to be a live puppet or a dead
puppet?
Well the maybe the dead puppet is better than
the live puppet, it depends on where your
going.
Then he’s on the bed, and the blue fairy
comes down and says well you’ve been honest
and courageous, “bang!”
now you’re real.
Then they have a little part, and that’s
just exactly right, they got that exactly
right.
That’s part of the hero mythology, it’s
the rescuing of the father.
Student: Why do you have to rescue the father?
Otherwise you’re a corpse.
You’re a historical creature, you’re a
cultural creature.
You cannot live without your culture.
You think you can, but you can’t.
it disappears, and look, I’ll give an example.
In the Mesopotamian creation myth, which I’m
going to tell you about next week, one of
the things that happens is that the first
round of Gods, so they’re like primordial
forces, they’re pretty damn careless, and
they kill their father.
They make this place to live on his corpse.
That’s where we live, we live on the corpse
of our ancestors.
We live in the society, it’s dead, it’s
the product of dead people.
It’s got this dead element, but we’re
living on it.
They’re very careless, they kill it, so
they render it completely dead.
Well what happens is Tiamat, who’s the Mother
of Chaos, she comes flooding back and she
thinks, “oh you killed the thing that protects
you.
You just wait to see what happens.”
That’s exactly it, if you kill the thing
that structures you, you won’t know it – it’s
like Nietzsche’s prediction from the death
of God.
You killed this, think it doesn’t make any
difference, - wrong.
It’s like the Striders protecting the Hobbits.
If you get rid of the thing that protects
you then chaos comes flooding in and you have
no idea what’s possible.
We do, though, because we lived through the
twentieth century.
We know exactly what’s possible.
Hundreds of millions of unnecessary deaths,
that’s what’s possible.
We’re lucky we didn’t blow the whole damn
thing up, and we still could.
People pursing their dead ideologies – you
don’t rescue the dead Father, than you’re
the puppet of death, that’s what you are.
Okay, on that cheery note.